[Music]
does the switch launch lineup sound a
little disappointing to you well you're
not alone but it just got a little
better as Nintendo has confirmed three
more games coming to the console on day
one I'm Matt this is a game spot news
update and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to keep up on all of our
coverage of nintendo's new console
nintendo announced that shovel knight
treasure trove shovel knight Spectre
torment and fast rmx will all be
available when the switch launches next
week spectre of torment is a standalone
expansion to shovel Knight while
treasure trove is a renamed version of
the original game that includes all the
DLC fast rmx on the other hand is a
fast-paced racing game that features a
local split screen and online
multiplayer and in my opinion it looks a
little bit like f-zero Nintendo said
that there will be more than 60 indie
games on the switch this year and will
be able to take a look at some of them
during an Indies showcase stream on
februari 28 at 9am Pacific the switch
itself launches on March third and will
continue to deliver coverage on the
console leading up to and after its
release but for now you can check out
our unboxing video in which we take a
look at everything that comes with a
switch
you